so if it wasn't obvious there's a lot of
backroom games out there and this is one
of them
this is the complex a backroom
experience or something like that now i
i know that there's been a lot of
backroom games but to be perfectly
honest i still don't really know what
the backrooms is all about other than
being a series of rooms in the back i
know that it has to do with falling
through
clipping through reality there's a
difference i don't know what the
difference is but that doesn't mean that
i don't recognize that there's a
difference and then you find yourself in
the background and there's no escaping
the back room
not the back room
september 22nd 1986
the spookiest year of all
well this looks nice
i mean it's i'm not [ __ ] on the back
rooms that's not what i'm doing i like
the back rooms in essence the essence of
the back backgrounds is good i like it
it's really something special it reminds
me of the scp
games from way back when especially
scp-087b
given that it's an endless series of
repeating rooms that are inherently
liminal
in a way
i don't know what the hell is happening
here
the only difference being you were going
down a stairwell in that one and then
you were going into some mundane looking
rooms filled with horrors beyond your
comprehension in the other one
very different
the same what was my point i don't even
know
i don't even remember
oh
and there you go
that is how it happens
one thing first
one thing you know first thing you know
first thing you know
you're taking a coffee break by your
tv next thing you know
you clip through the floor and find
yourself in the back rooms and here i am
wow
well this one actually
really nails the feel
i really feel like in 1986
and i feel like i'm in the back rooms
that's a little more rumbly than it
needs to be also why is the game smaller
i get why the game's square but the game
seems to be smaller for some reason one
second oh god
never mind it doesn't like it it doesn't
like me i'm just gonna leave it also why
is my camera darker in obs do i have a
filter on this colors look way up what
is wrong with you god when i don't put
you on night vision because i didn't
feel like putting the hold on everybody
this is very very important now we got
it now we're dialed in
now we're going into the back rooms lexi
and you'll just have to deal with the
sizing issue it's not my fault not my
problem that's an editing problem
and you're an editor
a good editor a great editor a fantastic
editor i never questioned anything about
your editing
you're doing great
don't kill me
okay
thank you
i'll make the content now
all right what am i doing
what um
the back rooms
are
a series of rooms well they're not even
really a series of rooms i think a room
is defined by an enclosed space
usually separated by walls and a door
or maybe even it doesn't have to have a
door on it but it needs to be kind of an
enclosed space okay don't like that area
i'm slow why am i slow
i run out of breath
am i a weak baby
am i a little baby i can't run for [ __ ]
apparently
i'm actually very impressed with the
feel of this it really does feel like
i'm alone
in the back rooms freshly divorced
trying to get by on my day job
and yet the boss keeps asking me to do
more and more and i have to sleep in the
break room just to be able to get by
and then i fall through the floor and
then i find myself stumbling and
hobbling is that different over there
i'm detecting a slightly different
oh
it is a slightly different hue
i don't like the darkness i don't know i
don't like the darkness i don't like the
darkness over there
but this is a different hue
and also the pillar shape seems to be a
little bit
different
what are you what what are you what is
someone with you what
hello
is this important is that just a way to
run away from a monster when it's
chasing me
when something's trying to crawl up my
ass i'm gonna crawl at that speed
through a hole to try to escape or is
that just a gap
oh i don't like the darkness
i'm gonna go ahead and say it i don't
like the i don't like the darkness
i don't like none of the darkness
darkness ain't something i like
did i hear
something
could have sworn that i heard something
but i might have been mistaken
oh
i say oh but it
like i get it looks a lot similar here
but this is fundamentally different from
what i was seeing before right
listen i think people are getting bored
hit him with a jump scare and then hit
him with a fun fact but don't tell him
what order you're going to hit him with
a man okay all right okay
green
[Music]
no yes no
i don't know
i don't know what i'm doing is there's
something following me
there better not be something following
me can i zoom can my eyes zoom yes they
can
i can zoom with my eyeballs
that's really incredible
oh
god
um i don't know if i'm
so what was that all about why the light
kick on that's not something that
usually happens here as far as i know
but i don't know really what happens
here because of my first time here
i don't know how much longer i can
wander aimlessly in the back rooms
without finding anything
interesting kind of conceptually
malevolent
it's leaving me with the yearning desire
to scream what are you what are you what
are you what oh i thought it was a it
was like an among us character i was
about to say leaving me with a distinct
urge to scream at the top of my lungs
you you telling me you wouldn't get in
the back rooms and start screaming
i'm not saying for help i'm not no baby
i ain't no baby but i'll i'll be
screaming just because i want to feel
the emptiness with the song of my soul
hello who's there
anybody
i feel like they'll just call attention
to all the monsters trying to sneak up
on me
you know i turned a corner and i don't
know what i was expecting
i thought it was eyeballs it was not
eyeballs no i feel like i've been going
pretty much
to a different area for a very long time
i don't but i feel like i might have
been skirting the outskirts of it i'm
gonna go in this dark corridor you can't
stop me lixie and pump up the ambience
make him real spooky real spooky get
whales of the damned ah not cut him
kind of i thought it was gonna be a lot
spookier than that i can't
i do
i definitely i definitely heard
something there was definitely something
else there
you guys heard that right
i ain't crazy
i ain't crazy okay well i seem to have
reached a corner
so i'm assuming there must be corners to
this ah no no it's not this goes on
forever
am i supposed to go towards like the
center that's a different color
i'll feel a little more warm and vibrant
and welcoming
that definitely points me towards
something that i know that it's gonna be
good for me
what
oh
[Applause]
i don't know i tried to say a word there
but it didn't come out what was that
were you waving at me giving me those
come hither flaps
oh you dick
oh you
big spooky dick
what was that supposed to be are you
kidding me
oh you're kidding me aren't you
oh you're giving me the reach around
the run around whatever expression is
correct that's the one you're doing
something
just click
not like click like aha click like
sounded like
there was again
you heard that right oh red
red
i like the red room
red
red
wait a minute
red
dead
red dead
i really don't know what the come hither
like
thing was and it really disturbs me that
uh i followed it and it didn't jump out
at me
that bothers me what did i just see did
i just see legs
did i just see a leg was that crazy i
don't know i was kind of turning my head
i'm not sure if i saw it
or if it was just in my imagination it's
weird you kind of see the same space for
a very long period of time and it just
like all blurs together but your mind
starts to fill in the gaps of things
it's really just like
showcasing that our perception of
reality is based on a bunch of
things we assume to be what they are but
doesn't necessarily mean that they are
what they are and so we just are left to
fill in the gaps ourselves and we don't
even realize it most of the time it's
like when we look at something you know
after moving your eyes real quick your
brain backfills the data in
that's why when you look at a clock the
second that you look at it seems a lot
longer than the other ones because your
brain is literally going back and
filling in the gaps in between when your
vision was completely blurred in the
motion of your eyes
backfills data
you don't realize it
i'm not making that up most of the stuff
that i say in these videos is [ __ ]
but that one actually is true i may not
be explaining in the right technical
terms but it is
in a sense what the frick is going on
there
upgrade
we got an upgrade
oh
ah
back rooms two
oh [ __ ]
oh man i can't wait
huh
hey
oh wahoo
hey yeppy
wait a minute wait wait whoa wait a
minute something's changing
table over there riding over there
some kind of
vent hole sign
is that hole meant for me
is that my hole
oh i had a flashlight this whole time
not that
it's a texture on the wall
okay
okay freshly frozen foods
you lied to me
how could you do that
all right whatever
fine
ah more back rooms back to backrooms
[Applause]
the original is best for me anyway
that's weird
ah
rail
oh
it's it's kind of one of those things
where you look at ai generated images
and you kind of look at and you're like
oh my brain initially thinks that the
thing but then you look deeper at it and
it's like your your recognition senses
go all haywire and it's not the thing
you thought it was it's not the thing at
all it's actually a big spooky face look
see up there in the crack
bossy whoa
you didn't notice that did you
anyway
did i just did i actually just see a big
spooky face
i hallucinate something
i probably did but whatever now i'm
starting to clue in that like this isn't
a thing where i cannot make progress i
think it's just like no matter what
i'm always going to be able to move
forward and do something i just don't
always know if it's going to be valuable
to do it
so i think if i just keep going towards
what appears to be
relatively different things it's always
going to offer me up something different
that is until something comes out and
kills me what is with this
i'm getting vibes of circus
i'm getting circus vibes what
weird
it is amazing how captivating this is
for me playing this even though there is
absolutely nothing happening like this
is a lot of nothing
and yet i'm enthralled
i'm really
into it
and i'm
what
is that the same
area that i was in before
this the same
might be the same i can't tell
i'm channeling every ounce of gamer
instinct i have accumulated over my many
years of being a professional gamer of
which i am and you cannot dispute that
it's proven
i get paid to do this that makes me a
professional
and yet
there i keep hearing
thumps thuds
thunks
thwomps
funkuses
i keep hearing them
and i don't think it's just the noise of
the wind
it really seems like there's something
here
oh [ __ ] is that the same red room
is it really a loop ah man i must be not
going the right way then there's gotta
be another way then god if i go all if
if i somehow manage to go all the way
back to the beginning i'm gonna be
extremely pissed first ghost that pops
out of me i'm going to punch in the dick
and if it doesn't have a dick i'm going
to punch it in the closest approximation
of a dick
noise
noise
noisiness
is that good or bad should i be afraid
of that
i'm more just excited to hear anything
don't be gone
are you serious
are you serious
you're serious right now
oh did i somehow make it back here oh
that's the same
where am i going how does that connect
back here wait that doesn't make any
sense how did it connect back here
theoretically that shouldn't have
god my sense of direction is all jumbled
up i might be completely wrong about
that but it doesn't seem like that
should
hello
ah no it's a light on a wall i thought
it was a there's a lot of things in the
distance here that really look like a
shadowy figure of some kind standing in
the distance but apparently not
well one can only hope that i don't
spend an eternity here slowly losing my
mind
succumbing to the madness that was not
exterior of my own self but was within
me all along
one can only hope that that does not
occur
i hear i hear i hear
i hear
where
where
go on
what is that all about i feel like oh
that's the same oh i saw this
then i have been going in a big circle
what's with the thing that waved at me
you guys saw it i'm just gonna slowly
lose my mind maybe there was something
up else in like the uh backrooms two
area that might have led to somewhere
else if all these kind of interconnect
then there might just be something else
there why is that shorter than the other
areas
i don't know okay that's the yeah that's
that
oh
hey i saw that
what are you doing what are you doing
what do you think you're doing huh what
do you think you're doing you think
you're messing with me huh no oh god are
we
how mysterious
mischievous
you think you can pull that on me huh
not today i saw that and i don't like
that okay so if i backtrack through here
there might be another area um past the
frozen area into the tall section that
does contain some other way to get
somewhere else but i'm also starting to
think that this is just a big
uh static map
and therefore nothing is really all that
different
oh why is that so dark
was that always that dark
is that always that dark why are you so
dark
what's going on what's over there
oh i don't like it
i turn my back on it because i don't
like it okay i'm gonna go this way now
because i don't think i've been i went
that route what
hi
hello
how are you good to see you
okay
interesting very strange
peculiar even
and it doesn't help me at all
i'm going in the darkness
and nobody can stop me
please stop me somebody stop me he's
somebody stop me where am i oh i saw
something
hello
what was that urge from groaning you
know you give me anything i'll just
slowly lose my mind even if there was
nothing you know someone could just make
a game and they could program absolutely
nothing in it it's just a level and
you're running around you tell me it's
something spooky and i will make up all
the spooks myself i will scare myself
every time i don't need anything that
actually jumps out at me i like my my as
soon as my mouth opens and i start
pouring out my own insanity that's when
i start losing it and i am currently
losing it because there's nothing else
happening here and if i have if there
has been something and you saw it and i
didn't please let me know down in the
comments below because i can't even
imagine i can't handle that knowledge
right now that there was something that
occurred and i did not see i'm guy can't
what
is this
did i
did i make it back to is this the
beginning because that would be
something that would that would be
really
really sad
if that happened you know the from what
i know about the back rooms and i will
read up on a lot of what it is because i
know
what no i keep thinking that there's
something there
something's peering around i don't know
if that's by design or if it's just a
sheer coincidence but i think there's
something there but i will look up into
what the back rooms is and i'm gonna
like really get some understanding of it
because there's like there's clearly
there's
yeah maybe if i read the story or watch
the videos from that one person that
makes videos about it regularly then
maybe i might know a little more about
it but i don't
i don't know anything about it
other than that it's a bunch of rooms i
thought that i was on to something when
i found that
you know back rooms too oh i didn't
actually go back there and i meant to go
see if there was like another part of
that that actually had something in it i
bet there was
huh
okay i have to go to the bathroom i'll
be back you stay here watch over
everything and don't let anything get
you okay if something comes you write in
the comments a command and it'll move
this is a live stream after all or
something like that huh
[Music]
anything anywho i gotta find that tall
area hmm
have i been there before or is that i
think that might still be the same as it
was that might have been a red herring
because that's where the frozen food is
when in reality
there's a little smoky in here
a fire and a fire in the back rooms
would be real bad
oh hey wait a minute
what
no
what was that
hello
hi elevator what
huh
oh
did i win
did i really just lose my mind for like
30 minutes where all i was supposed to
do was find oh
all i was supposed to do is find that ah
i see
now this is exploring the topic of
liminality
and i know very well about liminality i
don't actually that's false confidence
but i say everything as if i know what
i'm talking about and then everything
will fall right into place
just as i planned
but also
i never understood why people thought
this was creepy
i get it now
i suddenly understand
this is awful
oh i hate it i hate it
i hate it a lot
turns out i hate it
oh what is that i see
i'm zooming what is that over there
i really hope this is in the dead end
because i'll be i'll not only be
disturbed i will be angry
i don't know why i chose to go this way
this is probably not the best way i
think i think like the developer of this
game is probably or the developer of the
background is probably just like why is
he choosing the stupidest place to go
and i'm just like that's just what i do
i can't help myself i always do it i go
the path that you didn't expect anybody
to go and i either break the game or i
have a terrible experience and everyone
yells at me and i'm just like i'm just
trying to be me
oh god i hate it
oh that was a big waste of time all
right great
but i'm just trying to be me
i'm trying to do what i do
which apparently is
i win
i knew it
i knew it i knew it my genius intellect
was 10 moves ahead of yours that's that
underwater shortcut took me right to
where i needed to go no one would have
thought to go there except for me and my
huge brain god you can't even fathom the
magnanimity of my my mindfulness
is this supposed to be
ah
well
there's the thing all right if either my
genius is
oh you i know the truth when i see it
this is the path that's going to lead me
into the truth
oh
oh
ew
i hope that's not what i think it is
oh hey
freeze that's interesting
hello may i come in
are we going into the liminality of a
giant mall
huh
well that's peculiar i don't know if
there's a point to this other than being
mostly
museum-esque
in terms of just
walking around
but
i can't help but feel
like i'm missing something
i just can't shake the feeling that i'm
that people are yelling at me you know
whenever you're recording a video and
you know you're doing something that you
think is right but many other might not
think and you can just feel a cacophony
of maybe hundreds of thousands even
millions of people that are screaming at
you and your idiocy you ever get that
feeling
i'm feeling it
right about now
never mind
oh you fools you have no idea how smart
i am and how incredible my mind is those
were cheers not screams of admonishment
i am incredible
hello
dining hall
oh no oh what the hell
hello
there's a hotel from the shining
this is also very liminal but i want to
go to the dining hall i'm very hungry
[ __ ]
okay over here
dining hall
okay good i thought for a moment i was
gonna be lied to
oh boy another crawl space
yippee
frick
well that was short-lived and i feel
that oh
fine i'll leave now i said what was with
the tentacle man
waving at me from behind a pillar
what was with that
what was with this
is that breathing out here
i better not be breathing
i made it what the hell
wait okay i can't be this much of a
genius
right i can't be i can't
i got lost in the back room for like 30
minutes and i'm plowing through each of
these new areas in like two
am i the indie am i am i the idiot
oh frick you and me
don't even think about it
no
i'm gonna shine the light in your face
watch out i'm naked oh my god
is this my floor this is this my floor
should i should i get on this is my
floor oh no it's down my floor
on my floor
okay
still don't know any more about the back
rooms still don't know how i got here
still don't know who set up all these uh
elevators well i'm not listening to that
nonsense huh
i'm going this way
screw you
not a good idea i should have gone the
other way
i'm gonna go this way now i'm gonna go
the way the arrows told me because the
arrows have never led me astray and i've
actually never had arrows before so i
don't have any bases with which not to
trust them
i'm starting to get that feeling that
people are yelling at me again but it
doesn't matter
doesn't matter is that the same red room
as before it can't be the same because
the elevator was definitely not there
oh
definitely sound like breathing
oh yeah
something's real breathy over here what
if i go back to where the elevator was
you know
what if i go in and again is he's just
gonna loop me around
i mean there it is
but if i go in it again
what does that even mean
if it just takes me on the same loop i'm
gonna be very mad
i feel like i'm getting that feeling
that people are yelling at me again i
get that feeling in my heart
it's gonna be this is gonna be the same
freaking love it's gonna be the same
goddamn look
it's gonna be the same loop
it's not
fascinating
where am i i can't see [ __ ] is this a
city
what
oh what am i even looking oh whoa oh hey
all right
all is as it should be
and uh the deep rumble is definitely not
horrifying
hello hi what's up
oh
wow
oh too bad i can't focus on that or else
i think i'd be worried about that
happy birthday something something
something oh the back rooms
[Music]
hello
okay
kind of nice actually the back rooms
kind of gives off the vibe that you
stepped into someone else's dream
accidentally that's really what it feels
like and not in a cthulu esque like we
are all the dream of the eldritch gods
more just like you actually just slipped
into someone's dream
like oopsie poopsie you are
that's weird
you are just
a figment of someone else's imagination
for a bit
nothing come run at me real quick before
the elevator doors close
all right whatever
ah well this looks nice
hmm
what are you
what is this oh
liminal
very liminal
whoa
whoa
oh
it's like uh it's like the cube
oh
very fun
but very weird
plan
nice
i just got the feeling that i'm missing
something and it's not yeah that's not
nice
oh my lens is spotty where's my lens
splotchy
my eyeballs i mean oh
whoa
i love it okay this is less liminal and
more awesome
whoa
all right the appeal is quickly lost i
thought it was more of like a winter
wonderland but
yeah less less i guess
hello
grandma
this seems like a grandma-esque house
it can't be that
nothing
am i missing something
i mean i do what lights
wait a minute i remember
there were two lights above the elevator
two lights above the elevator four
lights on the outside of the house it's
not christmas lights
it's it must have something to do two
four i've seen two now i see four i
can't get around the back there's
invisible walls there's one over there
one over there four over here
what does it mean
and those are in the side where this
elevator is so there's
there's something to do with that
they're red lights it's not like they're
turned green so i've done nothing to
like activate them which means i don't
think they work like that
excuse me
are you alluding that i i went
i turned into trash
like i fell down a trash chute is that
what happened to me
[Music]
what was going on what was with the
thing
the thing that bugs me the most about
this is i saw a flappy arm
and it beckoned to me
and there was nothing else about that
that was absolutely nothing
it is there's nothing that probably was
a deeper puzzle in there that i didn't
figure out because i didn't solve any of
it and i barely scratched the surface of
it but i'm not going back in because
i'll lose my mind more than i already
have anyway that was the complex
fascinating why is it what's with the
three dots dot dot it's in the middle of
the where the word is but either way i'm
not happy i'm happy about it i i enjoyed
that but i don't know what was going on
there you have a mission there's there's
a link to this game in the description
okay you figure it out and then you get
back me okay bye
[Music]